hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen zu einem von minecraft video
ich habe bei sehr vielen youtube
angesehen dass dieses spiel schon
gespielt wurde deswegen dachte ich mir
recht in einer von viel ich mache auch
dieses spiel heißt gut bei new world und
ich hab ich ja auch komisch kann wie oh
mein gott das ist ja augenkrebs pur wir
lassen wir mal auf normal wir können
hier sehen wer es georg schiff sprint
interactive pickup objects of the
temporary store scheiße wir haben keine
dauerhafte tor schieben meinte limited
wir kriegen einfach mal auf play game 3
und dann sehen wir schon das alter ist
das springen da stand da gar nicht bei
den auswahlmöglichkeiten das ganze game
soll wirklich horror sein also wir
können
ich mache mir jetzt schon in die hose
ich werde mal einfach ein bisschen
sprinten wir können einmal entlang
laufen können hier hinten durch können
nicht hinten durch jetzt ganz tief ins
spiel wo wir die tür aufmachen habe ein
gott war es ein comeback
ich bin verdammt noch mal tot doch
vielleicht einfach auf und schauen was
passiert
den rekord fakt ist dem shape okay hier
bin ich wieder und er steht auf und ich
kann jetzt tatsächlich kann ich
reinlaufen irgendwie nein es ist alles
anbrennen ich habe es bei ein paar
youtube angesehen und durch gekippt und
da habe ich mir nur gedacht scheiße dass
sie tatsächlich sehr gruselig aus und
wird auch tatsächlich noch sehr gruselig
ich laufe jetzt einfach mal herunter und
wie kann ich denn wie mach ich noch
meine torte war dass ich es ja genau auf
seine torch und wo muss ich denn lange
vorne kann ich um laufen hier kann ich
definitiv mich rein hier kann ich auch
nicht weiter die sendung ganz normales
fällt hier vorne kann ich jetzt kann ich
auf einmal durchzugehen das denn wohin
ich das ist das hier so mein gott mein
gott er geht doch nicht er geht doch
nicht wirklich gerade ergeht ich habe
gerade in die höhle rein
er ist in die perfekte höhle
reingegangen ich habe hier vorne wieder
ein paar fackeln dann jetzt hier durch
spenden und irgendwann denke ich
manchmal einfacher machen und dafür aber
wie mache ich das der stirbt der
blödmann hab ich ihn getötet oder ist er
jetzt bin ich hier rumlaufen wie krieg
denen ich kann nicht mal mehr eine
fackel an machen ist es nicht möglich
dass ich mich wie eine fackel mitnehmen
oder kleiner man kann sich leicht
moment darum geht es
auf einmal läuft er los ich werde ja
nicht mehr wo muss ich ein auch nur ich
bin draußen kannst du vielleicht haye
bleibt da drinnen wo man gottes
verdammter gott ich kann muss dann kann
ich mich irgendwie wo bin ich denn hier
schon wieder kann ich auch und jetzt und
einfach weg vor ihm kommt er dann noch
irgendwie
ich weiß nicht ob ich richtig gelaufen
bin ich weiß nicht ob der zombie da
hinten noch kommt ich weiß auch hey guck
mal einfach nach ob ich hier drin noch
irgendwelche fackeln sind auch komme
eine fackel wer in gottes namen packt
sich einen redstone in seiner die grafik
ist ja unfair ist das wirklich ein
redstone grafik ist ja so unfassbar gut
fährt ja nicht mehr das ist ja echt
kamera mal ganz gedruckte zombie dahin
der zombie kommt nicht mehr und wir sind
jetzt quasi ich in einer stadt wie pxe
dies soll ich mal springt sich irgendwo
noch ein paar fackeln die ich irgendwie
mitnehmen kann als räume definitiv
nichts drin wenn ich hier rein laufe
okay damit kann ich gar nicht
interagieren dessen brawn war nicht da
irgendwie nein kann ich auch nicht rein
ist jetzt einfach mal in die pigs in und
schaue ob ich hier vielleicht irgendwo
faktisch dem shared ich habe jetzt gar
eine fackel angemacht und schwimmbad
wird für ok alles klar kann ich mich mal
irgendwie mich schlafen legen oder so
deswegen wie der nächste tag x anregt
und ich nicht dauerhaft auch kommune
fackel doch nicht es ist ja alles sehr
verblutet aus und als wenn hier
tatsächlich nicht so die ihm eine fackel
ist schon wieder aufgegangen von fox
zeigt wieso das ist der brunnen ich habe
tatsächlich nur noch eine fackel und ich
weiß jetzt nicht was ich mit mit einer
fackel noch irgendwie hier großartig
was das war's ich habe das wirklich bei
einigen youtube und durch gibt weil
vorsehen wollte sie ja okay wie wird das
vielleicht ich hab gesehen die waren in
der hölle und da gerade jumps case und
da war das war supertoll gewesen und
ende ich laufe erst mal zurücknehmen mir
hier die beiden fackeln mit laufe dann
quasi einfach wieder hoch ich weiß es
ganz genau ob ich das mit dem krieg
unbedingt machen muss aber ich schaue
mir ganz gut ob ich nicht so einfach auf
darunter herkomme ich muss das mit dem
creeper machen ich glaube hier oben rein
macht die tür auf blabla hoch hier
kommen auf einmal ein clip heraus ich
versuche zurückzulaufen es täglich der
kühler guckt mich an der explodierten
rappelt sich wieder auf ich kann ganz
normal diesmal wieder hier durchlaufen
quetsche mich die komische für jetzt
nehme die fackeln mit und schleiche mich
jetzt mit angezündeter fackel irgendwie
an dem zombie hier vorbei
mein gott wie so läuft er denn mal so
schlecht wir haben jetzt hier vorne in
der welt gelandet
der zombie ist immer noch hinter mir
aber ich schaue jetzt mal ganz gut ob
ich nicht hier noch irgendwo anders lang
an guck mal hier ist doch mein gott hier
vorne ist der gang zu ende und wenn ich
wieder zurück laufe sehe ich schon dass
der zombie auf jeden fall richtig heiß
ich glaube hier hinten lang weiß dann
dass ich hier hinten in die stadt rein
komme kann auch theoretisch über eine
brücke darüber laufen um auch dann um
das ich dann dass ich dann hier
irgendwie ins ja da bin ich jetzt in der
stadt taixing weil die ball schon drin
hier hinten aber auch schon mal nicht
kann ihn ja noch weiter gefallen es noch
ein haus wo aber auch nichts drin ist
und wenn ich hierhin in die kirche laufe
die grafik ist schon hammer eine fackel
an gemacht da hinten ist auch nichts und
jetzt kann ich quasi einfach nur wieder
zu dem schwerter hinten laufen weil ich
meine ist ja alles vorbei so bei der
kirche steht halt nur die kirche herum
ich bin den ganzen häusern war ich drin
ich könnte hier runter fallen aber dann
bin ich gut und wenn ich jetzt hier
hinten zum schwert in laufe und mit dem
schwert interagieren möchte und mir
irgendwie ein schwert möchte habe ich
mir gedacht dass ich jetzt eine
schwerfällige danach in die kirche
aufgegeben die gegen zombies kämpfen
kann aber dann kommt mit mauer und dann
da steht jetzt nur noch die kontinuität
idee da das ganze wohl damit jetzt eben
die beendet ist würde ich sagen ich fand
das spiel sehr geil von grafik ich habe
mich irgendwie ein zweimal kurz
erschrocken als der kombi kam und die
laue runter gefallen ist und zwar
bereits nichts außergewöhnliches und ich
hab halt bei den anderen youtuber nur
gesehen das ist halt ultra krass sein
soll ich weiß nicht ob das einfach nur
der erste teil ist vom world ob da
vielleicht noch mehr kommen soll oder ob
es dann noch einen zweiten oder dritten
teil schon raus gekommen ist den ich
einfach nicht gesehen habe so ähnlich
wie minecraft storyboards und etwa denke
ich ich stelle ich mir das gerade
irgendwie vor wenn ihr das schreiben das
gerne kommentare kette ultrabook darauf
dass einmal in den zweiten teil zu
zocken und
wenn es euch gefallen hat wie seine
bewertung wollen und wir sehen uns dann
vielleicht mal irgendwann bei einem
nächsten teil wieder frei